シュガーソングとビターステップ
−UNISON SQUARE GARDEN−
唄：はじめしゃちょー
タンバリン：トマトクン　マラカス：けんすけ
超天変地異みたいな狂騒にも慣れて
こんな日常を平和と見間違う
rambling coaster
揺さぶられながら
見失えないものは何だ？
平等性原理主義の概念に飲まれて
心までがまるでエトセトラ
大嫌い　大好き　ちゃんと喋らなきゃ
人形とさして変わらないし
宵街を行く人だかりは
嬉しそうだったり
寂しそうだったり
コントラストが
五線譜を飛び回り
歌とリズムになる
ママレード＆シュガーソング、
ピーナッツ＆ビターステップ
甘くて苦くて目が回りそうです
南南西を目指してパーティを続けよう
世界中を驚かせてしまう(夜になる)
店員さん：失礼致します
(I feel 上々　連鎖になってリフレクト)
蓋然性合理主義の正論に揉まれて
僕らの音楽は道具に成り下がる？
こっちを向いてよ　背を向けないでよ
それは正論にならないけど
祭囃子のその後で
昂ったままの人
泣き出してしまう人
多分同じだろう
でも言葉にしようものなら稚拙が極まれり
最高だってシュガーソング
幸せってビターステップ
死ねない理由をそこに映し出せ
惜しがったって等速で明日は来ちゃうけど
脳内天気予報のアップデートを果たしたなら
みなさん、コメントを書きましたか？
えー8月最後
夏休みの最後ぐらいに
動画に出そうと思ってるんで
みなさん是非
今の時間にコメントよろしくお願いします
なんでも書いてください
多分8月の終わりくらいに出せると思います
よろしくお願いしまーす
someday　狂騒が息を潜めても
someday　正論に意味がなくなっても
feeling song & step
鳴らし続けることだけが
僕たちを僕たちたらしめる証明になる、QED！
ママレード＆シュガーソング、
ピーナッツ＆ビターステップ
生きてく理由をそこに映し出せ
北北東は後方へ　その距離が誇らしい
世界中を、驚かせ続けよう。
ママレード＆シュガーソング、
ピーナッツ＆ビターステップ
甘くて苦くて目が回りそうです
南南西を目指してパーティを続けよう
世界中を驚かせてしまう夜になる
I feel 上々　連鎖になってリフレクション
goes on　一興去って一難去ってまた一興
Foooooooooo
【はじめしゃちょー　エンディング】
痛いっ
一難去ってまた一興
【はじめしゃちょー　エンディング】
あ〜
あっ
【はじめしゃちょー　エンディング】
みんなー
コメント！
待ってるぜぇ〜〜
ハァハァハァハァ